BMW presents the seventh generation of
its five series the business class best
seller has various new developments to
offer its aerodynamics have been
enhanced and that means more power with
lower fuel consumption and what customer
wouldn't like that we test drove the
540i with a sizeable 3 liter engine
the core of the brand in many respects
is the 5 Series in the 3 series and of
course the 5 Series has got great
history back from 1972 or dare I say 44
years ago this car really did create a
segment that has become synonymous with
the core of BMW you see the brand being
shape from the top you know 7 Series the
i8 but if you asked a lot of customers
they see this car as one which really
stands for everything BMW is positioned
for its an icon with plenty of power the
standard 6-cylinder engine produces 250
kilowatts for a top speed of 250
kilometers an hour the new model
Sprint's from zero to 100 in 5.1 seconds
prices start at fifty seven thousand
seven hundred euros in Germany rear
wheel drive makes this agile car live up
to BWW slogan the ultimate driving
machine
the month is car reviewer Montes points
out that German mid class sedan segment
includes the BMW 5-series the audi a6
and the Mercedes e-class a BMW has
always been regarded as the sportiest of
the three brands with this standard
fitted drive mode switch Matas can
choose between sport and comfort and if
the car has the optionally available
adaptive suspension the sport mode gives
you a stiffer right so you can take
curves extremely fast of any of sport
gear on tan tan man Jesus out of
Ecclesiastes nail on the coffin bhavin
visually the 5-series looks like its big
brother the seven series that's due to
the kidney grills in front which join up
with the headlights and give the five
series a much broader look the M Sport
package costs in an additional four
thousand six hundred euros comprises a
range of technical and styling extras
[Music]
[Music]
isn't metal dimaggio do kick head of
BMWs exterior design division explains
the changes to the five series front the
hood now fits directly onto the upper
edge of the kidney grilles and
headlights it's a manifestation of
greater precision and attention to
detail with the kidneys being curved I
got the precision too tight but it did
the twin grills a trademark of every BMW
have been made noticeably larger and BMW
has revived its old connection between
the grills in the headlights which makes
the car look broader early BMWs also at
the grills and headlights in one
connected strip from the near don't
loyst info button under some via off by
the auto v rocker shaft high class and
high performance the interior features
quality materials the interior has
changed a lot from the predecessor it's
now more dynamic and less cluttered the
Bowers and Wilkins surround sound system
is 1400 watts of power with 16
loudspeakers transforming the five
series and to a concert hall on wheels
let's get behind gun montes points out
another feature he loves in this car
when you activate the parking sensors
you first get the bird's eye view camera
which you can find in many models these
days but you can also adjust the view to
get the image of the car from any
perspective I'm Sean Montes can size up
the parking spot and see whether he can
open the doors wide enough Wow
[Music]
myfoxatlanta sums up his impressions the
BMW 5-series is a beautiful vehicle but
beauty comes at a price and so this car
will probably first serve as a least
company car when it's done that for
three years a regular car buyer will be
able to afford it used sup how fast
things yet
you